un enfrentamiento cada vez más familiar
la policía chocó con activistas del
clima en el oeste de Alemania por la
ampliación de una mina de Carbón del
ignito Sasha es una de los cientos que
ocupan el pueblo abandonado de luxerata
en un intento de obstaculizar el
proyecto Si queremos obtenernos al
acuerdo climático de París Entonces
tenemos que actuar Aquí y ahora y
tenemos que demostrar que no podemos
confiar en la política Porque al fin y
al cabo depende de nosotros usar
nuestros cuerpos para impedir que la
policía desaloje luzerat el plan es que
el pueblo sea demolido este mismo
miércoles para dejar paso a la
ampliación de una mina que produce 25
millones de toneladas del grito al año
el más contaminante de todos esos tipos
de carbono La policía tiene que
desalojar a los activistas y su
asentamiento para que comiencen las
obras de demolición
Este despliegue es un reto porque como
hemos visto tenemos que esperar un
enfrentamiento con manifestantes
violentos
pero los sombríos informes sobre el
futuro del planeta han empezado a traer
la simpatía de la opinión pública hacia
este tipo de manifestaciones como en
Austria donde los activistas que
bloquean el tráfico recibieron el apoyo
de los científicos
entiendo perfectamente que los jóvenes
busquen otros métodos y no podemos
dejarlos solos con eso
[Música]
no son delincuentes no son extremistas
son jóvenes preocupados que simplemente
eligen un método que les parece
apropiado las protestas en Alemania
forman parte de las crecientes tensiones
por la decisión de Berlín de reactivar
el carbón como medio para hacer frente a
la crisis energética una práctica que
amenaza directamente sus objetivos
climáticos en un momento en que se han
registrado temperaturas récord en Europa
en